Sall Stein is an author playwright and
editor his new book native sons reflects
on his friendship and collaboration with
the late author James Baldwin during
this our 15-minute event marking the
80th anniversary of James Baldwin's
birth you'll also hear from historian
Henry Louis Gates Jr good morning ladies
and gentlemen dr. gates members of the
Baldwin family my name is Jack Shapiro
I'm the senior librarian here Clinton
and on behalf of our faculty and
students and New York City's Department
of Education I'd like to welcome you to
DeWitt Clinton High School on this very
special occasion the 80th anniversary of
the birth of James Baldwin one of our
favorite sons class of 42 before I say
anything further I'd like to emphasize
that this day belongs to Saul Stein as
much as to his classmate James Baldwin
as you know today also marks the
publication of Saul's latest book native
sons and it was Seoul's idea to have the
celebration here where it all began some
fifty years ago
needless to say we at Clinton feel very
honored this high school is also my alma
mater though I graduated some 20 years
after Saul and James Baldwin during my
teen years I had frequently heard about
Baldwin that read some of his moving
fiction and eloquent nonfiction in
college and then shortly after
graduation in the late 60s as a
fledgling English teacher I read Saul's
remarkable best-selling novel the
magician however it wasn't until I
returned to Clinton about 19 years ago
as a librarian but I learned these two
outstanding literary figures and I had
most likely studied at the very same
tables in this very room furthermore I
learned in time that there were and are
many other luminaries who
at our school and it's 106 years before
the morning is over I hope you will all
have a chance to view our Wall of Fame
in the media room behind you
depicting only a small number of Clinton
alumni who have distinguished themselves
in the Arts and Letters I'm sure you'll
be as surprises and impressed by the
number and importance of the names as I
was when I began to research the proud
heritage of DeWitt see this long list
must certainly attest to the excellent
record of public education that our
school is achieved but I should also
like to point out that the talents of
people like James Baldwin and Sol Stein
were nurtured in the Fertile artistic
and intellectual ground of our great
city and now I'd like to turn the
microphone over to our other favorite
native son Saul Stein writer teacher
editor publisher and class of 1942
I am not running for elective office
ever I want to thank Jack Shapiro and
also Geraldine Abruzzo the principal and
Miss Jordan for lending us this place I
promise to return it this afternoon I
want to greet all the members of the
Baldwin family and the Friends of
Baldwin and friends of mine and all of
the people who have come here today to
celebrate what would have been Jimmy's
80th birthday and at the same time
celebrating the book that deals with our
collaboration as editor and writer that
produce notes of a native son
I want to thank an editor who edits
editors melody guy
and my assistant Michael Schmidt Heyman
who helped me daily for the two-year
effort and putting together this very
difficult manuscript and helping me
produce what I have in my hand today
Richard Hewitt I see him now one of the
great publishers of the last century who
made Eldridge Cleaver's soul on I sell 2
million copies and who is celebrating
his 93rd birthday in a few days
where is Paula Horne
kotas there you are Paula is the
photographer who took the picture that's
on the front of the first edition of
notes of a native son a remarkable
photograph
I wanted to thank Hilton halls also and
he's stuck in Miami somewhere because he
came up
Hilton halls of the New York or some of
you know him he came up and he was the
first person to look at the letters that
were were unearthed and is the man who
actually forwarded my introduction to
the editor of The New Yorker who sent me
the only letter I've ever received in my
life that I'd like to frame he will see
us all on television again most
particularly I want to thank Henry Louis
Gates Jr for his encouragement that made
this event possible
thank you and thank you for your
profound understanding of what Baldwin
stood for a few words about the building
we're in on October 29th 1929 the stock
market crashed that day was the day that
mayor Jimmy Walker came up here to
dedicate this building that's the good
news part of that day
within a couple of years this school had
an enrollment of 13,000 students and was
the largest high school in the world
ten thousand copies of the Clinton news
were produced weekly Jimmy and I caught
this fast-moving train in 1939 before
your visit today previous visitors at
this school who spoke also included
Andrew Carnegie Douglas Fairbanks Babe
Ruth Lou Gehrig Max Schmeling who
clobbered Joe you know why it was
clobbered by Joe Lewis and for the World
Championship
Mickey Mantle Jim Brown and went in
Marsalis who actually graduated from
this school as well and sent me a note
that said he's on tour what can he do
but he's here with us in spirit
why and how does this one high school
soar
the motto of DeWitt Clinton is seen a
laborious without work nothing let's try
to remember that in the Tower of this
building Jimmy and I work on the magpie
magazine which was a prize-winning
literary magazine done entirely by
students and our work consisted of
criticizing the other people's stories
and defending our own
we our faculty adviser was in man by the
name of Wilmer stone who would meet with
us every Friday afternoon up in the
tower which was named the magpie tower
and would read our stories to us in the
world's worse
monotone it was very painful but we
learned an important lesson the words
have to do it not the acting of the
writer then yet all over this country
where you have writing schools and
writing seminars and advanced writing
courses what happens is that the
students read their writing and if they
get published someday it is going to be
read on paper and they don't have a
chance to practice that but this school
did that for those of us who are lucky
enough to be here when I met Jimmy
Baldwin here I was 13 and he was 15 and
our differences were substantial
Jimmy was black I was white he liked Ben
I liked women he assumed that his
ancestors came here in Chains I knew
that my mother and father who were dry
backs illegals came over the border from
Canada when they shouldn't have in order
to escape a very bad situation in their
home country Jimmy and I even had very
different attitudes toward food remember
we were depression kids and we very
often had lunch together and Jimmy would
stretch out lunch for two hours every
time making sure it would last and I
gobbled mine up in five minutes because
I didn't want anybody to take the play
too
so you can see we had different
approaches to most things I want to
point out one picture which is of a
little boy sitting in Jimmy's lap one of
the things that happened is that Jimmy's
family and my family became close and
it's a closeness that with several
people lasted for half a century
that little boy nearly half a century
later is sitting somewhere in this
audience there he is
I want to say something about David
Baldwin who was the closest brother to
Jimmy and who soon after I met Jimmy
became soon after years after became a
friend of mine and we ended up working
together and had an emotional tie that
lasted a lifetime a Jimmy's funeral you
may remember that Bertus the Jimmy's
mother and the mother of you who are
here was in a car that had been hired
for her sitting in the back seat at a
terrible time for her and I managed
through the street to get to the street
side of that and opened the door and
Bertus greeted me as if I were one of
her kids and we were talking and then I
saw David coming down two steps and he
saw me but he couldn't get over to the
street side and he couldn't get the
could the car door open on that side and
I wish a photographer had caught that
moment because David reached over the
car and I reached over from the street
side and after stretching and stretching
we touched fingers and that was the last
time I saw him
we you know I want to touch on one point
because in that 1984 introduction to the
book Jimmy starts out by saying that I
forced them to write notes of a native
son look nobody was ever able to force
Jimmy to do anything not to arrive on
time nope he nobody ever made him live
where he didn't want to live he he found
a way to avoid the bane of every writer
that I know a day job and I was horribly
jealous we honed those essays to
perfection made a standard so that
anything that fell below that standard
wouldn't go into the book that was very
important because the salesmen all said
that essays don't sell and we wanted an
exception for this book and we also
found that one of the problems with
books of essays is sometimes they don't
lead you on from chapter to chapter to
chapter and so the order of the essays
was very important to us the salesmen of
course when the book was presented told
us how essays don't sell this book of
essays has been delivering royalty
checks twice a year for 48 years and I
hope is a good example to many writers
of pace to really work hard on a book of
essays and I think you all know that
some years back a very distinguished
board selected notes of a native son as
number 19 of the hundred best
non-fiction books of the century
Jimmy and I accomplished the second
miracle when we worked worked together
we used to talk for hours and hours and
hours and boy did we talk and then the
miracle happened it's a miracle I would
like to recommend to the rest of the
world my color disappeared and Jimmy's
color disappeared and never came back
except once and I want to tell you about
that exception I was studying Anglo
Saxon which is a language in which
hardly anything is worth reading but it
was a requirement of the PhD at Columbia
and I was out at Jones Beach trying to
master this language and it's sunburned
the beach and sunburned me top to toe
and I was lying in my bed of pain at
home and Jimmy came to visit and he saw
me sunburned and boy did he laugh in
1954 there's a picture by the way of the
graduating class of MacDowell Colony
1954 we both had fellowships there and
on one occasion we both needed to head
into the city and I had a rattletrap car
and Jimmy came aboard and we started out
in those days they would not the
highways that exist today it was a long
ride and it started to rain and rain
harder and harder and at one point we
saw the water was starting to build up
and we were going to get out of the car
because we saw a you know state trooper
and we thought he might tell us whether
week it was passable and he screamed at
us get back in the car we didn't realize
that electric wires were down in
you know those puddles of water and we
thought that since we were halfway
should we turn back and no the storm
seemed to be moving north so we decided
we're going to go and at one point we
went over a hill I can see it in front
of me and as we reach the crest we look
down and there was nothing but water and
the car kept the wheels were spinning it
had a little bit of traction every once
in a while but we were hydroplaning and
Jimmy said this is going to be a sad day
for American literature
well we we spied two parallel lines and
we figured that they had to be something
between them to cross over and that's
what we tried to steer toward and sure
enough there had been a way to cross and
we got over to the other side and we
survived to do about 15 books each so
had a happy ending I see quite a few
young people in the audience in fact
probably I can say that with possible
exception of my great publishing friend
that everybody is young in this audience
I want to take you back to a time 1957
Jimmy and I were commissioned by the
theatre guild of the air which was
sponsored by the US Steel hour to do a
teleplay that is a play for film or
television which was based on Jimmy's
essay equal in Paris which is nonfiction
and they said they wanted a synopsis
first Jimmy didn't like writing anything
like a synopsis and I have to admit I
didn't like writing anything like a
synopsis because all you get is plot you
don't get any sense of character so we
wrote a short story and we called a dark
Runner and we told them it was a
synopsis and they never knew better they
said all right so that's my advice to
writers who are present in the audience
when the important meeting came Bill
bartilson who was managing director of
the theater guild asked us to lunch and
found out that his assistant couldn't
book a table in any restaurant that he
had his credit card rather his his his
accounts in they would not permit
Baldwin to enter and they finally found
the place that was sort of a little off
the beaten track and the three of us met
and mr. fight Olsen said to us we're
ready to guess the phrase now is
greenlight it go forward and we only
want one change make the black
protagonist white well what Jimmy and I
said is not reproducible here this is a
family event too but we tossed it and I
forgot about it pretty much until we
moved after 36 years from Scarborough to
Tarrytown and opened more than 30 boxes
that hadn't been opened in decades and
there was the story there was the play
and remarkably the best thing in this
book are the letters the exchange of
Frank letters that we expected nobody in
the world would ever see and I want to
thank Random House One World Valentine
for letting us do those letters as art
that was so important they are done
photographically so you can see the
typos and the misspellings and the
marginal comments and everything else
just as we saw them when we got them
someday if I live long enough we may
actually redo that play as a film and I
would put all of the things we wanted to
do back in and the protagonist will be
black and gay and you can do all those
things on television now without making
us still have a heart attack I have some
news for you I think this is something
that most people perhaps all people here
don't know and this is about Jimmy in
the early 1950s there was for the only
time in American history an organization
of some 300 leading American
intellectuals of right left and center
in the same organization in opposition
to all forms of totalitarianism these
were people who understood the profound
dilemma of that time in which many
artisans and many intellectuals favored
the Soviet Union which had been a beacon
in the 30s for so many American
intellectuals but was now a slave state
and killed its own people by the
millions just as the Nazis did I have a
piece of their stationery today with me
and you can see this roll call of 300
names most of them will be familiar to
you but I will call off a few Arthur
Schlessinger jr. Lionel trilling
Reinhold Niebuhr J robert Oppenheimer a
philip randolph her win Shaw David
Riesman Upton Sinclair John Steinbeck
James Johnson Sweeney Bruno Walter
Robert Penn Warren Thorton Wilder James
T Farrell Peter Varrick Saul Bellow
Norman Cousins John Dos Passos Arthur
Kessler George Balanchine and art of and
alphabetically right after Balanchine
was James Baldwin who young as he was
stuck his neck out way out to be part of
apprecia
movement that saw the similarities of
20th century tyrannies in which no one
white black or yellow was free Jimmie's
most important theme can be stated very
simply when he said we he meant we
Americans when he said us he meant us
Americans I believe James Arthur Baldwin
born 80 years ago today was one of the
greatest American essayist ever the fire
was in him reading him is a joy because
he writes so well and we heard so much
because as we read his rich texts we
realize how poor we are now that he is
gone he also became a fantastic public
speaker who could extract laughter and
applause from an audience at will he was
a novelist a playwright a quite
wonderful human being but above all for
me a great conspiratorial friend and I
hope every one of you has or can get a
great conspiratorial friend I hear
voices my wife is a psychiatrist and if
necessary she can testify that I am
slightly sane but my last novel the best
revenge the character based on my father
though he's dead talks to the hero all
the time in the two years that I was
working on this book completing what was
for me a labor of love Jimmy kept
talking to me and I answered him every
time no matter who was looking happy
birthday Jimmy and stick around
it's my privilege to introduce the next
speaker he has taught at Yale Cornell
and Duke and is now the chair of the
afro-american studies department at
Harvard with an integrated faculty in an
integrated student body as a young man
he spent a year working as an
anesthetist at a hospital in Africa and
he has since devoted himself to waking
people up he he has edited dictionaries
and anthologies and written a dozen
books some of which you will see on
display here professor gates was
graduated summa [ __ ] laude from Yale and
earned a PhD from Cambridge University
he received one of the very very first
MacArthur Genius fellowships
twenty-three years ago he rediscovered
the first novel in the United States
written by a black person even as a
publisher I read very very few books
twice but I'm now reading professor
Gates's thirteen ways of looking at a
black man for the third time please
welcome a polymath a man who was
rediscovering America a man of great and
varied learning Henry Louis Gates
that's one good brother right there
right there ladies ever give it up for a
Saul Stein really
so you were blessed to as she said no
Jimmy and know him so intimately but on
this Jimmy's 80th birthday I'm sure he's
looking down on us I think that he would
want you to know that he was blessed to
- blessed to have the love of such an
intimate friend and the literary
brilliance of such a sensitive and
caring editor together your
collaboration was one of the great
moments of interracial harmony and
intimacy in the history of American
literature
yeah brother maybe you'll head at me I
haven't have a manuscript right here you
know I want my books to be yielding
royalties forty-eight years later that
is astonishing starting to write essays
right now this is like the end of Wizard
of Oz Irv Eisen you were there and you
were there and you were there Gloria was
there get to meet Jimmy's brother and I
called him little David I mean boy looks
so much like his uncle it's amazing but
to be able to see the woman who took the
photograph of Jimmy on that that very
important canonical work as you hear it
was the first black author I ever saw
the first black author ever saw was only
covered that book 1965 and you know
black people wrote books 1965 I was from
Piedmont West Virginia population 2000
in the year 1950 the year I was born
DeWitt Clinton had 13,000 people in his
eyes go our whole town had 2386 black
people and nine-tenths of them of my
cousins which made it rough when it came
time to Dayton because you couldn't date
you couldn't date white kids he's not in
a day time you know what I mean and then
the editor who edited Eldridge Cleaver's
soul on ice 93 years old got to give
that brother hand too
what an important moment in the history
of african-american letters and soul
sign has brought you all here today to
celebrate
Jimmy's 80th birthday and the
publication of the testimony to their
marvelous collaboration I hope you all
will buy the book and get sold to sign
it because it's a very very important
historical document I want to tell you
how I met Jimmy and the role that he
played in my life I'm calling him Jimmy
I never would call him Jimmy to his face
I'd be lying if I said I called him mr.
Baldwin I called him mr. Baldwin to the
very end it's called the Welcome Table
and you'll see why let's check the stage
take one young eager black American
journalist that was me and one aging
actress singer star that was Josephine
Baker and one true luminary of black
letters and that was mr. James Baldwin I
was 22 years old a london-based
correspondent for Time magazine and I
felt like immortal invited to dine at
Mount Olympus my story for which Time
magazine had agreed to fund my trip to
France was to be on the black expatriate
in Europe and one of my principal
subjects was James Baldwin and another
one was Josephine Baker who being a
scenarist to her very heart put one
condition on her meeting with me I was
to arrange her reunion with James
Baldwin whom she hadn't seen since she
left France many years before to live in
Montecarlo
now I don't know what she made of me
with my gold rim cool blue sunglasses
and my bodacious two-foot-high afro
you know Cornel West Africa Cornel West
ever looked like a crew-cut next to my
afro I look like a ball of black cotton
candy walking down the street and it was
combed out I had my afro seen on it I
was smoking boy haha but I was received
like a dignitary of a foreign land who
might just well be a long-lost son and
so we set off in my rented Pujo bearing
precious cargo from Monte Carlo to some
Paul de Vence in Provence going to Shea
Baldwin but in case I was in any danger
of forgetting that a living legend
Josephine Baker was my passenger baker's
fans mobbed my car every time we stopped
at a traffic light invariably she
responded with elaborate grace partly
playing the star who expects to be
adored
partly the aging performer who is simply
grateful to be recognized when Jimmy
chose son Paul devons for him his home
it was a quiet village surrounding the
tiny ancient walled city in the Alpine
foothills that rise from the
Mediterranean Sea his house which is
still there and still owned by the
family is situated among shoulder-high
Rosemary hedges acres of peach and
almond orchards and fields of wild
asparagus and strawberries and grey par
burs and it was under one such great
barber at one of the long harvest
Taber's tables out in the garden that we
dine that night the line from the old
gospel song aligned Baldwin it quoted
toward the end of his then latest novel
inevitably suggested itself to being I
am going to feast at the Welcome Table I
am going to feast at the welcome table
and feast ladies and gentlemen we did we
did at that long welcome table under the
Arbor the wine flowed food was served
and taken away in James Baldwin and
Josephine Baker traded stories they
gossiped about everyone they knew and
many people they didn't know and they
recalled the details of their marvelous
lives they had both been hurt and
disillusioned in the night
it states and had chosen rather to live
in France they had they never forgot or
forgave at the table that long warm
night they recollected the events that
led to their decisions to leave the
country of their birth and the
consequences of these decisions the
difficulty of living apart from home and
family of always feeling a part in their
chosen homes and of the pleasure of
choosing a new life the possibilities of
the untried a sense of nostalgia
pervaded that evening for all their
misgivings they shared a sense curiously
of being on the winning side of history
now people said James Baldwin was ugly
and he himself said so sometimes but
ladies and gentlemen James Baldwin was
not ugly to me there are of course faces
that we could not see simply as faces
because they are so familiar that they
have become icons to us and Jimmy's
Village was one such face and as I sat
there in a growing haze of all and
alcohol studying his lying face I
realized that neither the Jimmy I had
met mischievous quick eyed and empathy
funny nor even the Jimmy I would come to
know could ever mean as much to me as
James Baldwin my own personal Oracle
that gimlet-eyed figure who had stared
at me out of a fuzzy dust-jacket
photograph when I was 14 years old for
that ladies and gentlemen was when I met
James Baldwin first and discovered that
black people too could write books you
see that was my James Baldwin and it was
strictly private property no trespassing
allowed I was attending an Episcopal
Church camp high in the hills of Eastern
West Virginia overlooking the South
Branch Potomac River about three hours
west of Washington DC 18 miles from the
mill town of Piedmont West Virginia
where I was born it was August 1965 a
month shy of my 15th birthday now this I
should say at the outset was no ordinary
church camp
our twin thing
that summer were these first is God dead
and secondly can you love two people at
the same time this was the Episcopal
Church you don't even have to believe in
God to be an Episcopalian
now remember dr. Jeff hago was big that
submerged so Episcopalians never were
ones to let grass grow under their feet
after a solid week of complete isolation
a delivery man bringing milk and bread
over to our church camp told the head
counselor and I'm quoting that all hell
had broken loose in Los Angeles and that
the colored people there had gone
absolutely crazy then he handed him a
Sunday paper screaming the headline that
Negroes were rioting in some place
called watts now I for one was
completely bewildered because I didn't
understand what a riot was we're colored
people being killed by white people or
were colored people killing white people
now watching myself being watched by all
those white campers after all how many
black Episcopalians can there be in the
state of West Virginia and you know what
it's like to be in school in the old
days you're in school and every time
something black came up all the white
kids and teacher would say well Skippy
how do you feel about Abraham Lincoln
I love Abraham Lincoln sir watching
myself being watched by all those white
campers I experienced that strange
combination of power and powerlessness
that one feels when the accidents of
another black person affects your life
simply and only because both of you are
black for I knew that the actions of
people I didn't know and would never
know people from some place called Watts
Los Angeles had become my personal
responsibility just as surely if the
black folk in watts have been my
relatives in the village of Piedmont
some 20 miles away
now sensing my mixture of Pride and
discomfiture an Episcopal priest from
New England where else handed me a book
later that afternoon from the cover the
wide spaced eyes of a black man
transfixed me notes of a native son the
book was called by someone named James
Baldwin
was this man the author I wondered to
myself this man with a closely cropped
natural as we used to call him brown
skin splayed nostrils wide lips so very
Negro so comfortable and proud to be so
it was the first time I had heard a
voice capturing the terrible
exhilaration and anxiety of being a
person of African descent in this
country from the books first few
sentences I was caught up thoroughly in
another person's sensibility but this
time a black person sensibility the book
performed for me the function that Adam
performed the function of naming naming
the complex racial dynamic of the
American cultural imagination coming
from a tiny segregated black community
within a small white village I knew both
that black culture had a texture a logic
of its own but also that it was
inextricable from so-called white
culture that was the paradox that
Baldwin identified and negotiated and
that is why I say his prose shaped my
identity as an african-american by the
questions he raised as much as by the
answers that he provided if blackness
was a labyrinth James Baldwin would be
Mike
my guide I couldn't put this book down I
raced through this book then others
written by him filling my commonplace
book or my notebook with his marvelously
long sentences full of commas and
qualifications of course the biblical
Cadence's spoke to me with a mordant
immediacy because I too was saved when I
was 12 and was intended to be a minister
for the next two years that is until the
Episcopal Church and yes James Baldwin
saved me from that dreadful fate I
devoured this man's books first I read
notes of a native son then I read nobody
knows my name then I read the fire next
time and then when I was 18 I read
another country I began to imitate a
style of writing using dependent clauses
whenever and
wherever I could much to my English
teachers to grin consider the following
example
quote and a really cohesive society one
of the attributes perhaps of what is
taken to be a healthy culture has
generally and I suspect necessarily a
much lower level of tolerance for the
Maverick the center the man who steals
the fire then have societies in which
the common ground of belief having all
but vanished each man in awful and
brutal isolation is for himself to
flower or to perish
ladies and gentlemen there are 16 commas
in that sentence in my essays at school
I was busy trying to cram as many commas
into my sentences as I could until mrs.
Iverson my eighth-grade English teacher
forbade them unless as she put it they
were absolutely necessary
now I of course was not alone in my
enrollment and as much as it vexed me
James Baldwin was most certainly not my
private property
when Baldwin wrote the fire next time in
1963 he was exalted as the voice of
black America the success of fire next
time led directly to a cover story in
time in May of 1963 and soon he was even
spoken of as a contender for the Nobel
Prize for Literature perhaps not since
Frederick Douglas a century earlier had
one man been taken to embody the voice
and the face of the American Negro by
the early 60s Baldwin's authorities
seemed nearly unchallengeable what did
the negro want that's an easy question
to answer
we'll ask James Baldwin the puzzle was
is anyone who read him closely should
have recognized that his arguments
richly nuanced and self-consciously
ambivalent were far too complex to serve
straightforwardly political ends if
James Baldwin had a central argument it
was that the destinies of black America
and white America were profoundly and
irreversibly intertwined each created
the other each derived its identity from
the other and each could destroy the
other America's interracial drama is
Baldwin put it head and I quote not only
created a new black man it has created a
new white man too in that sense he
continued quote the history of the
American Negro problem is not merely
shameful it is also also something of an
achievement for even when the worst has
been say it said it must also be added
that the perpetual challenge posed by
this problem was always somehow
perpetually met unquote now if you think
about it these are not words to speed
along a political cause
they did not mesh well with the rhetoric
of self-affirmation that the black power
liberation movement required yet
couldn't his sense of the vagaries of
identity serve the ends of a still
broader braver politics unfortunately
and we have to be honest because we are
scholars some black nationalists in the
mid 1960s the late 1960s didn't think so
and they attack Jimmie mate acting for
being too conservative they attack him
for being too liberal and they attacked
him shamefully for being homosexual but
Jimmy always elegant and gracious never
once never once responded to the various
black writers of amiri baraka
who since of course apologized and
changed his mind the late Eldridge
Cleaver and several other writers Jimmy
never once degraded himself by
descending to their level to respond to
those vicious attacks he and I stayed in
touch on and off through the intervening
years as I graduated from the University
of Cambridge and then became an
assistant professor at Yale I even
brought Jimmy to Yale to deliver the
first Richard Wright lecture and he was
very nervous let's just say much
Johnny Walker was consumed that day
sometimes out of the blue I'd get a call
and he'd invite me to meet him at the
ginger man over by Lincoln Center when
he was back in New York and sometimes he
would introduce me to his current lover
or speak of his upcoming project one
lovers name was skipped it was a tall
man used to be an actor and Jimmy did
you know Jimmy was a poet too and he he
published his book of poetry and several
of my friends had an Akane me said we
want to talk to you and I said we want
to talk about they said we got Baldwin's
new book of poems I say yeah it's great
to go yeah brothers dedicated to skip
I said not this skill I love Jimmy I
didn't love him that way
but I didn't return tucson paul devons
until shortly after Jimmy's death in
1987 when my wife and I went at Jimmy's
at the invitation of Jimmy's brother
David to discuss a project I hadn't been
back to San Paul since 1973 that summer
in August so I'm Paul had changed
remarkably in the 20 or so years since
he settled here
the demand for vacation homes and rental
property had claimed much of the
farmland that once supported the city
and supplied its needs luxury homes dot
the landscape on quarter acre plots and
in the midst of this congestion stands
James Baldwin's ten acre oasis the only
done divided farm acreage left in some
Paul only now the great barbers are
strung with electric lights there we had
a reunion with Bernard hassel Jimmy's
loving friend of so many decades and I
met Lucien hoppers Berger the friend to
whom Giovanni's Room is dedicated after
a wink a week of much drinking and
reminiscing David Baldwin asked me just
when I'd met Jimmy for the first time as
I recounted the events of my visit in
August of 1973 David's wide eyes grew
ever wider he rose silently from the
table and he went downstairs and many of
you been to Jimmy's house take the
staircase down to his study we get down
there there's a wall of books by and
about Henry James faces you as you enter
Henry James James Baldwin's muse and
then David emerged with a manuscript in
his hand
threw it on the table and he said this
is for you he had handed me a play the
last work Jimmy completed that as he
suffered through his final illness and
the play is called the Welcome Table
I'll tell you about the play it's set in
the Riviera at a house much like Jimmy's
house and among the principal characters
are the following someone named Edith an
aging actress
singer star a Creole from New Orleans
Daniel annex Black Panther a fledgling
playwright with more than a passing
resemblance to Cecil Brown and finally
Peter Davis a young black American
journalist Peter Davis who has come to
interview a famous star and whose
prodding questions lead to the plays
revelations was I should say a far
better and more aggressive interviewer
than I was but of course Baldwin being
Baldwin had transmuted the occasion into
a searching drama of revelation and
crisis reading it made me think of all
the questions I had left unasked that
magical night in August of 1973 it was
and is a vain regret Jimmy loved to talk
and he loved language but his answers
only left me with more questions
narratives of decline have the appeal of
simplicity but James Baldwin's career
will not fit that mold unless a writer
is extremely old when he dies he once
wrote in which case he has probably
become a neglected institution his death
must always seem untimely and this he
wrote in 1961
giving us fair warning this is because
he continues a real writer is always
shifting and changing and searching
reading his late essays I see Baldwin
embarking on a period of intellectual
resurgence and energy I think he was
finding his course again exploring the
instability of all the categories that
can continue to divide us as Americans
as he wrote in his essay here be
monsters an essay published two years
before his death and with which he chose
to conclude his collection called the
price of the ticket and I quote each of
us helplessly and forever contains the
other male and female female in male
white in black black and white we are a
part of each other many of my countrymen
appear to find this fact
exceedingly inconvenient and even unfair
and so very often do I Jimmy wrote but
none of us can do anything at all about
it
unquote ladies and gentlemen we needed
to hear those words two decades ago we
need to hear them today
times change Madonna our very own
zeitgeist goddess has recently announced
her interest in seeing a film made of
Giovanni's Room which was one of
Baldwin's greatest hopes in the late 70s
Robert DeNiro and Marlon Brando were
said to be interested in the project but
nothing came of an influential
intellectual avant-garde and black
britain has resurrected James Baldwin as
its patron saint and a new generation of
readers has come to value just those
qualities of ambivalence and equivocal T
just that sense of the contingency of
identity that made Jimmy Baldwin useless
to the ideologues of liberation and
anathema to so many black nationalists
in the late 1960s but then even as
fiercest antagonists have now welcomed
him back to the fold because like
everyone else
we love our heroes once they're dead I
suspect though I cannot prove it James
Baldwin wrote a decade before his death
that each life moves full circle toward
revelation once again my hero leaves us
with a question but whose revelation did
Jimmy have in mind his or ours thank you
very much ladies
so I'll ask me if I would why don't you
come up here we can both answer quest
could somebody get us two glasses of
water if you don't mind otherwise I'm
not going answer questions
yeah in the in the words of the great
black tradition ask me a question
yes stand up please oh you got to come
to that microphone because c-span people
have asked us to ask you to come to that
mic so you gonna be if you ask a
question on TV so this is your great
opportunity to be on television it's not
really a question per se um first of all
I just want to greet my family on my
name is Trevor Baldwin Trevor Baldwin
correct nice to meet you brother I'm the
son of Wilma and Helen Baldwin and I
think the thing I'm most interested in
is your experiences because that's what
a lot of us don't get to hear is those
candid candid talks that uh we we we
take from and we learn from ya so any
any experience is anything that comes to
mind that you haven't said in your
speech I think we love to hear to start
off our Q&A okay
so I'll reserve that cuz the other ones
are all in the book native son Jimmy was
I let's talk about his sexuality which
is very interesting to me in my family
the gates family we have three
generations of gay people so I was
raised even in the hills of West
Virginia with gay people and everybody
knew they were gay it's not like we're
the most liberal people but we love
family more than we loved anything else
people still were weird about it they
would make jokes and it caused
tremendous some anxiety particularly my
oldest cousin we called him Tuffy and he
calls him a tremendous amount of pain
but we were still very accepting within
the family but Janesville was the first
public gay person I'd ever I'd ever met
and I was telling his nephew that when I
went to the South of France when I came
to can we have four men all beautiful in
different ways all living with them at
the same time I was thinking that is one
busy brother right there
but I took my girlfriend with me because
I didn't want any confusion about what
was going on I said hi mr. Baldwin is my
girlfriend but um he was very
comfortable with his sexuality yeah he
didn't hit on people you know he was
just he was comfortable with it even
mature with it and I think of all the
pain that brother must have suffered in
the 50s gee and then when he wrote
Giovanni's Room the first ladies and
gentlemen the first african-american to
write a book with explicitly homosexual
characters with James Baldwin but a
short story written by Bruce Nugent
during the Harlem Renaissance and there
were a lot of gay writers in the Harlem
Renaissance there were so many gay
writers in the Harlem Renaissance it
could be called the gay Renaissance
County column was gay
many people think Langston Hughes was
gay Alain Locke was definitely gay
it was but they were all in the closet
deeply in the closet and you know our
people a lot of the evidence was
destroyed even by librarians and
archivists because they didn't want the
race to be embarrassed but Jimmy said
it's time to come out and to stand up
and he did and you know how how can you
estimate the amount of courage it took
for him to be black to be himself to be
gay to be sensitive to be complex to be
in the church and then come out of the
church you look at heroes when you you
know we don't need to look back to
phantasy pharaohs of ancient Nubia I
mean look at someone like James Baldwin
for courage there's never been anybody
more courageous in the history of the
African American tradition personally
professionally politically privately and
publicly than James Baldwin and I'm not
saying that just because it's the
birthers 80th birthday or because I love
in them wearing this marvelous new stamp
that the government just issued I'm
saying it because it's true if any of us
could be half as courageous in our
career I think that we could accomplish
great things yes ma'am
I don't have a question I just wanted to
give some information
my name is Louise Merriweather and you
mentioned Bruce Nugent and all of the
gay people in the 20s and I just want to
tell everybody there is a movie about
Bruce Nugent and it's called
brother-to-brother
and if you haven't seen it yet it won
the it went a prize at the one of the
festivals in Los Angeles and it will
soon be shown in New York so it's all
about Bruce Nugent and all of those
nervous let's go other two brother
that's great thank you thank you yes
could you come up brother to brother I
haven't seen it but I want to see it
Bruce Nugent was a great writer hello my
name is Miles Marshall hello miles
hi Don I'm a writer I actually have a
bound galley of my first book that's
coming hey congratulations okay I bring
that away but what you this is your
moment
Oh on TV which of book home it's called
scars of the soul are why kids wear
bandages when they don't have bruises
is it a poetry fiction actually it's an
essay collection si lo it's about
growing up the Bronx and seeing hip-hop
culture beginning outside of my window
and it's heavily influenced by Baldwin's
example all young black writers are
congratulations thank you very much and
incidentally I've relocated to France
also under the yeah also under the
influence of you know Baldwin is a
mentor Baldwin Ellison well you need a
place need a place to stay go down to
son Paul um I do have a question though
my question deals with um I guess the
intellectual atmosphere of America um I
did a recent interview with Aaron
McGruder who I'm sure you're familiar
with sure does the comic strip the
boondocks yeah I love like here in the
Daily News in New York I interviewed him
recently and having seen Michael Morris
Fahrenheit 9/11 also recently it seems
that um certain political ideas of being
laced with humor in order to get them
across to the masses and
reading the essays of Baldwin um some
things were funny but I loved his mind
the way his ideas flowed and one into
the other and it just seemed like there
wasn't as much humor or it seems like to
make it go down easier nowadays you have
to lay certain ideas with a certain
amount of humor and I didn't notice that
so much in Baldwin's work and I just
wondered if you had a comment about well
privately um he was hilarious it means
very funny he had a wry sense of humor
wicked nasty you know this body of just
great and there are lots of people here
know him a lot better than I do
you know I just I didn't know him really
that well but when I was with him I left
all the time right but you have to
remember when he's writing notes of a
native son in the fire next time it's
war and Emmett Till's 1955 right right
right
it wasn't a time for humor it was you
had these racists turning fire hoses and
on you know innocent college students
and lynching people at cetera et cetera
and so it called for a different kind of
disguise
and he had his own rhetorical style and
it was grabbing white America by the
throat really but in a way that made
them feel uncomfortable I think it's
most subtle rhetorical gesture Saul
indicated already was he he always said
us and we and it wasn't the way we would
say us and we meaning the
african-american community it was a
black man claiming America as his
claiming membership and ownership of
America itself I mean he never went
begging you know to the at the court of
of the American people he was I am with
you I am of you you know I am an
American Negro and so rhetorically he
was a master Saul said he's one of the
great essayist in the history of the
essay written in the English language
there's absolutely no doubt about that
fact when I when he came up to Yale to
give the Richard Wright lecture I said
to him you know long and let's imagine
let's make oh let's have a fantasy and
imagine that the racial problem in
America one day is solved which it will
be for
in one way or another it will be so I
said long after the issues that you have
written about are resolved people will
still be reading you but they'll be
reading you in expository writing
classes as an example of a master of the
English language and he looked at me he
said that's probably true now he looked
at me and said do you really think so
and I said oh yeah I stake my my whole
career on that right you could do no
better than to copy out as I did his
sentences in longhand I mean I wanted to
be James of all y'all Yeah right he
could just do so much with with language
and none of us writes like James Baldwin
today he was the man he was the master
and he's Henry James's greatest disciple
okay
you know I would say too he helped us
all find our voice you know just as
young black American writers and stuff
like that um I had a lot more examples
than you did when you're growing up um
you know becoming a writer um oh sure
but um but just the same he stands head
and shoulders above you know yeah what
else well good luck to you thank you
Sala gates my name is Toby Stein hello
Toby Stein and went on are you related
to song I am his baby sister is this a
setup question I have a feel what that
means is that when Jimmy started coming
to our house I was only four years old
and so he was a part of my family
from the time I was too young to have
any sense of color when I went to the
march on Washington the one that counted
the one that was August 28 1963 I happen
to be unemployed I was 22 years old and
I didn't have a job and I borrowed 22
dollars from my brother in fact it's the
only time I've ever borrowed money from
my brother in my whole life because I
thought that my parents who were then
long dead would um come back and
throttle me in some form we all have
ideas that our parents in my family our
parents come back and talk to us after
they're gone and I was dismayed by the
fact that Jimmy was on a list with all
kinds of celebrities like Lena Horne oh
there were all movie stars and singers
and not writers I mean this was in the
newspapers his name would be in there
and I found that later in life he seemed
distressed by being a celebrity rather
you know or being asked to speak for his
people that kind of thing and as an
admirer of your writing I'd like to know
if you have a similar conflict ever
because you're a celebrity between doing
your serious work and having a very
public face and name well I don't think
of mine first of all James Baldwin is in
the category up here and I'm down there
in the valley looking up at Mount
Olympus let's just get the relationship
straight secondly I don't think of
myself as a celeb I think myself as a
poor working-class colored boy from
Piedmont West Virginia whether I am in
you might look at me and laugh that I
just said how I think of myself is where
I'm from and I don't feel any
deprivation and feeling that I felt like
we had everything in the world we needed
in the colored community of Piedmont
West Virginia I had a mother god rest
her soul and my father my daddy's 91 -
right now he's 91 got a 70 year old
girlfriend
hello I don't wanna go there I have one
brother is chief of oral surgery over
Bronx Lebanon Hospital they raised us to
think we were little princes that we
could do anything we wanted to do Cornel
West once said to me think of how absurd
it was I was born in 1950 Cornell I
think in 1953 so both were born before
brown v board our parents raised us so
that by the time brown v board was
announced by the Supreme Court I was
four and you know you're pretty much set
as the Jesuits say by the time you're
five six years old
my mother was like a self-esteem factory
she made she told my brother me that we
were brilliant and beautiful every day
of our lives now you can tell a monkey
is brilliant beautiful in Hypnotizer and
they would start to believe it sooner or
later I didn't know if I was bringing up
you but my mother said that that meant I
I probably was of course one out of two
ain't bad maybe but all I'm saying is
that I go back to the preparation the
training the nurturing that brought me
into this room today and it's because of
a strong mother a strong father loving
stable hard-working deferred
gratification they believed in me they
believed in my brother they believed we
could do anything that a white racist
could not stop us from doing that the
only reason we would be stopped would be
because of George Wallace or bull
Connor's or over of Orval Faubus
if we get rid of them we could soar we
could be astronauts we could be
president we could teach it Harvard you
know we could do whatever we wanted to
do in this Cornell said think of how
absurd that was when they Emma till I
was 5 years old
Emma till I could just as easily been
walking down the street and been accused
of whistling at some white woman but she
didn't they didn't raise us to fear they
raised us to believe in ourselves in and
Excel when I drove up here car picked me
up an apartment in New York this morning
9:30 drove over here and I said there I
got here 10 o'clock I said here looking
at DeWitt Clinton High
Richard Avedon went here Jimmy Baldwin
went here they did that book together
nothing personal
1965 very rare book I have a copy signed
by Avedon signed by Jimmy I never
dreamed when I was at that church camp
that be walking into DeWitt Clinton I
did ever dreamed I comes to the Bronx
1965 that I would come to see where
James Baldwin had been a student and be
a speaker to commemorate his 80th
birthday my life for me is a miracle and
I'm not being disingenuous I can't but
I'm so afraid I'm gonna wake up
sometimes and I'm gonna be dreaming I'm
still stuck back in Piedmont West
Virginia in 1965 and I've just
fantasized the marvelous life that I've
I've lived I think that's a blessing of
God if you feel that way but I think the
people in this room would agree that you
are both a serious writer and a
celebrity well I'd like uestion wasn't
really about race it's really whether
you find a conflict between those two
things well um
does it keep you from your work no no
nothing peace means a month nothing
keeps me from my work it is the milk one
of the most gratifying things to me and
this has happened more since I started
doing documentary film series for PBS
and BBC said people will stop me on the
street and don't comment on my work now
most of my bother to stop you say nice
things to not everybody does they say
but you know I disagreed with what you
said in the New York Times yesterday but
I respect your right to say it or I
admire your point of view the worst
thing is being called an Uncle Tom my
handkerchief had a race traitor or
something like that because somebody
disagrees with you as long as they don't
do that and talk about your mother or
your father then it's it's very
gratifying it makes you think all that
work is worthwhile it makes you think
that you have a connection with your own
people it makes you think that maybe
just maybe in a small way you're helping
you know they're inspiring a young
person and so I take that responsibility
very seriously but I also insists on the
right to be myself you know I watched
the older generation when I was young
Charles Davis black man first black man
black American with tenure
English department at Yale if he and his
wife were going to fly in some way are
going to airport he would have worn a
suit
I mean been a Brooks Brothers suit he
would never would have gone like we
dressed today with t-shirts and and you
know sandals on because he was
representing the Negro people he was a
professor at Yale you know there were
strains on its what Jimmy called the
burden of representation when you had to
represent the people all the time it
just it works on you you never have any
time off you just you know you can't
just have a beer and go to the watch the
Mets or Yankees or something that's not
healthy you know it's not healthy we
have we need public lives but we need
private lives as well I love humor my
father's a funny my father makes red fox
look like an undertaker and so I never
wanted to lose my capacity to laugh to
crack jokes double entendres you know to
to shift back and forth between the
black vernacular and standard English
the language of the marketplace I wanted
to be able to function in the broader
society but also wanted to come home to
Harlem whenever I whenever I felt like
it and I think that our generation is
better able to do that can do that more
easily than the previous generations of
African American intellectuals anyway
thank you ladies and gentlemen thank you
Jack Shapiro we're ready to give the
building back yeah thank you
native sons is published by one world an
imprint of ballantine books visit
ballantine books calm slash one for more
information
next week on public lives a new
biography of Supreme Court Justice
Clarence Thomas you can find out more